bonjour gens retenaient remercie
beaucoup je laisse notre invité
politique ce matin vous êtes président
de la région grand est et vous êtes
médecin et c'est important pour les
sujets qu'on va évoquer dans quelques
instants on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour fabrice veysseyre
bonjour gens retenaient revanche pas les
journaux régionaux de l'est de la france
de votre région bien évidemment jean
rottner nous sommes en parlant du pass
vaccinale définitivement adopté hier par
un vote du parlement ultime vote des
députés après un parcours parlementaire
complet compliqué est ce que pour vous
c'est un bon outil ce padd vaccinale est
est-ce qu'il n'arrive pas trop tard dans
la vague omicron si ce débat du moment
ces débats du week-end dames c'est vrai
qu'il a été annoncé le 27 décembre de
mémoire par le premier ministre la vague
est arrivée on voit aujourd'hui les
chiffres qui interroge qui pose question
également est ce que on n'est pas en
descente et ce qu'on a on va pas vers
finalement une sortie de cette cinquième
vague sans trop de dégâts humains mais
quand même des hôpitaux surchargés c'est
le cas dans le grand est ce notamment
comment ça se passe dans les eaux
aujourd'hui comme partout en france
effectivement la situation est à peu
près identique c'est-à-dire que on sent
qu'on est dans une phase plateau et que
le chiffre commence à être plus
favorables mais la charge hospitalière
est toujours là savait très bien qu'elle
ait un décalage d'environ 15 jours et
donc la question qui se pose aujourd'hui
sur ce pass vaccinale qui a fait débat
qui le débat n'est pas encore finie
puisque conseil constitutionnel est
potentiellement saisie oui est-ce qu'il
est encore utile ou pas je crois que
finalement dans l'esprit moi j'étais
pour le passeur vaccinale dans l'esprit
des français il ne faut pas il faut être
extrêmement prudent extrêmement humble
on ne sait pas encore quel est le profil
de cette épidémie certains scientifiques
comment c'est à dire et alain fischer le
premier on risque d'avoir une période
d'accalmie en mars potentiellement oui
c'est possible moi je suis extrêmement
prudent extrêmement râble attendons
regardons et restaurer ce temps surtout
très prudent est ce qu'il aurait fallu
aller plus loin c'est ce que demandait
notamment les socialistes et rendre la
vaccination obligatoire ça aurait été
une des solutions je crois que
après après les mots un petit peu
particulier du président de la
république il y avait une forme
d'incohérence site effet si
effectivement il souhaite pousser les
français vers des vaccinations il aurait
fallu aller au bout des choses et dire
ok je prends la décision moi président
de la république de la rendre
obligatoire
l'état peut rester muet
je ne sais pas si c'est par manque de
courage politique en tout cas vous savez
dans une crise les mesures les plus
simples sont les mieux adaptées parce
que les mieux compris ce qu'est ce que
vous pensez que elle est définitivement
enterré ses excès nation obligatoire
parce que manuel da cruz ne ferme pas
complètement la porte elle est mise en
place en italie elle va être discutée en
allemagne
dans une période un peu particulière ça
s'appelle les élections qui ont lieu
dans deux mois et demi ou trois mois
donc c'est pas maintenant qu'à
vaccination obligatoire va être
introduite par le pouvoir
un mot sur on parlait des hôpitaux et de
la situation dans l'est dans les
hôpitaux est ce qu à une pénurie de
personnel dans les hôpitaux ont du mal à
recruter bien sûr mapaq les hôpitaux la
médecine libérale le monde de la santé
aujourd'hui est un monde en crise on le
sait sur lequel il faut non pas alors
secteur de la santé c'est bien c'était
surtout un signe aux hospitaliers ça n'a
pas été vraiment un ségur du monde de la
santé en france et je crois qu'il faut
qu'on regarde aujourd'hui d'urgence et
il faudrait que le débat d'ailleurs
présidentielle se concentre aussi sur
ces grands sujets de société qui
conditionne aussi notre avenir
aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup d'énergie
il y a le débat autour autour de ce fait
à débat sur la santé est absolument
nécessaire oui il faut redonner des
perspectives aux personnels hospitaliers
oui il faut permettre un aménagement du
territoire de proximité dans les grandes
villes comme de la réalité pour la
médecine libérale pour les paramédicaux
il faut revaloriser les salaires il faut
redonner confiance aux systèmes de santé
à denia ble ment et il faut que ce débat
se fasse et qu'ils soient sus surtout
suivie d'actions entre domaine autre
secteur où les tensions sont importants
c'est l'éducation nationale vous avez
compris dispositif mis en place non non
non non non et ça à faire le sentiment
sur le terrain moi j'étais encore cette
semaine
dans des lycées j'ai rencontré là aussi
sur mes visites beaucoup de parents
d'élèves ou d'enseignants qui
s'interrogeait cette année là oui parce
que ordre compte andré gall désordre et
ça a été un peu le ressenti pour tout le
monde y compris pour un certain nombre
d'autorités de l'éducation nationale qui
ont essayé de faire face d'accompagner
mais c'est vrai que ça a été difficile à
expliquer difficile à décoder difficile
à comprendre avec des attitudes de
parents qui disait moi je vais pas
tester mon enfant de 3 à 4 fois je fais
une attestation sur l'honneur et voilà
donc quand effectivement la situation
être compliqué contre les consignes sont
à comprise eh bien on arrive à un
système qui petit à petit se détourne de
son attention d'origine difficile aussi
pour les élus locaux est ce que ça se
passe mieux de que depuis le début de la
crise entre l'état et les élus locaux
c'est toujours compliqué est ce que
l'état a toujours un train de retard
pardonnez moi l'expression on voit que
les élus locaux distribuer des masques
ffp2 dans leur collectivité
l'état est un peu réticent et d'en
distribuer certes l'éducation nationale
est ce que là aussi il ya toujours un
décalage depuis le début de cette crise
moi je suis de ceux qui disent qu'en
tout cas l'état ne perd jamais à
s'appuyer sur ces collectivités locales
on est dans la même équipe de france on
va dans la même direction il faut qu'on
sorte ce pays de la crise il faut qu on
le relance y compris d'un point de vue
sanitaire
autre côté les collectivités peuvent
aussi faire preuve d'initiative et ne
pas être simplement que dans des
revendications de décentralisation et de
compensation financière mais aujourd'hui
certains centres ont peut-être de
manière caricaturale vous savez dit
souvent on se dit oui on veut
décentraliser on veut décentraliser
soyons nous force de proposition dans
cette descente ratée par exemple à des
présidents de région sont non je ne
ciblerait personne mais c'est toujours
un peu facile aussi de dire les tableaux
décentralisée soit une force de
proposition je prends de mon propre
exemple comme ça je ne lâcherai personne
mais quand on signe au niveau de la
région un plan de relance avec la
préfète de région nous sommes la seule
région de france à l'avoir fait c'est
abandonner sur le terrain on se fait
confiance on travaille dans la même
direction on parle la même langue on
partage d'efficacité de nos services et
on le fait pour notre territoire pour
nos entreprises pour l'emploi c'est sa
décentralisation intéressante on avait
un instant une image de masques à
l'antenne ça nous rappelle un débat d'il
ya déjà quelques mois les ffp2 vous en
tant que médecin vous le recommander
vous le conseillez il est plus efficace
ou non le match logique je vais vous
dire oui j'ai plus efficace on le sait
les études scientifiques ont démontré
j'étais pour venir dans mai à paris dans
le tgv dans le tgv je porte moi effet p2
pendant 2h40 je suis avec eux ils une
atmosphère un peu plus confiné qu'une
atmosphère extérieur je prends
aujourd'hui cette mesure de sécurité à
d'autres occasions j'ai amassé un masque
chirurgical là aussi les gens le
comprennent suffit qu'on leur explique
ils sont là aussi facettes des consignes
aux simples en capacité d'adapter leur
attitude sur la dernière question sur la
crise sanitaire puisqu'on a vu le débat
au parlement alors qu'il ya un débat sur
le fond mais aussi un débat très
politique est ce que vous redoutez
qu'emmanuel ma on utilise cette crise
sanitaire il s'accapare le débat
présidentiel nation il faut que le débat
présidentiel en tout cas sorte de la
crise sanitaire pourquoi on donne des
perspectives à ce pays qu'on redonne des
perspectives a osé l'hectare si on n'est
que sur la crise si on parle comme
mikron
passe vaccinale passe sanitaire
vaccination c'est parce qu'il va faire
venir d'autres pays bien sûr c'est
important bien sûr c'est majeur
aujourd'hui le pouvoir d'achat l'école
on l'a dit la santé l'environnement ça
ce sont des sujets de fond ce sont les
sujets qui vont permettre à notre pays
de souffrir un avenir un roman national
et l'emploi on va en parler en plus
manuels mâcon et chez vous dans votre
région cet après midi à chalampé c'est
près de mulhouse un déplacement sur le
thème de la réindustrialisation et de
l'attractivité industrielle de la france
il ya cinq sites alsaciens je crois
qu'ils sont concernés par le plan de 4
milliards annoncée hier soir par
l'elysée ces investissements étrangers
en france et il est à chalampé le chef
de l'état parce qu'un investissement
conséquent de basf qui va être annoncé
dédié à la création d'une nouvelle unité
de production d'un composant du nylon
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour votre
région ça représente combien d'emplois
est ce que vous savez c'est une
cinquantaine d'emplois directs et
beaucoup d'emplois indirects et à côté
de cette production de nylon il ya
surtout une unité d'hydrogène qui devait
être créé avec un autre industriel donc
c'est cette responsabilité sociale et
environnementale comme essayer de
développer autour de l'industrie cité
des ran industrielle s'est pas forcément
quelqu'un qui polluent c'est pas
forcément mauvais au contraire
l'industrie aujourd'hui est en train de
se révolutionner est en train de de
rentrer très fortement dans cette
responsabilité environnementale et on
accompagne ce projet c'est pour nous
pratiquement deux ans de travail avec
notre agence de développement avec le
business france c'est quelque chose qui
se fait vraiment en neuf et aujourd'hui
avec l'aide de l'état avec l'aide de
l'état ou business français entre autres
une agence de l'état donc on le fait de
manière tout à fait coordonnée efficace
et au delà des projets alsaciens il ya
encore d'autres projets qui sont
annoncées qui sont dans les tuyaux qui
sont en cours de négociation
je crois que c'était il ya une confiance
et une confiance d'ailleurs dans l'est
de la france extrêmement forte
aujourd'hui c'est par rapport aux
investissements étrangers à l'échelle
des régions dans notre pays la région
qui permet le plus de créer sur l'emploi
et ça c'est ça c'est assez intéressant
vous êtes heureux de recevoir le chef de
l'état aujourd'hui votre lait c'est
normal effectivement quoi le reçoivent
ses larmes sait très bien qu'il le fasse
depuis depuis notre région c'est positif
vous noterez notre région tient bien
d'un point de vue industriel et traverse
plutôt bien cette crise il ya quelques
défaillances que l'on accompagne mais là
aussi avec l'état avec d'autres
collectivités mais nous résistons plutôt
bien d'un point de vue économique et
d'un point de vue industriel c'est une
satisfaction sur cette question de
réindustrialisation et d'attractivité de
la france de faire venir les
investisseurs étrangers mettent à la
hauteur le chef de l'état lui je peux
pas dire qu'on est dans la même équipe
de france et dire après que fut chef de
l'état ne joue pas son rôle il est dans
son rôle effectivement la
réindustrialisation c'est un élément
majeur un élément majeur pour notre pays
et le président de région je suis qui a
entre autres la charge de l'économie est
naturellement est heureux de cette
nouvelle mais il contribue aussi
financièrement à lacanau tard beaucoup
je laisserais ceux qui sont en charge de
lancer l'annoncé venema quoi va passer
beaucoup de temps chez vous décidément
il pensait sa tournée sa tournée du
grand test mercredi sera strasbourg en
cette fois ci devant les députés
européens pour son grand discours de
lancement de la présidence française du
conseil de l'union européenne vous avez
publié hier une tribune c'était dans le
journal du dimanche avec renault moon et
carole delga sur le siège de strasbourg
strasbourg coeur battant de l'europe et
vous dites dans sa tribune dès sa genèse
le parlement était implantée à
strasbourg il va sans dire que sa
présence est un gage de rayonnement pour
le grand est et pour la france qu'est ce
que vous attendez des manuels macro
mercredi et durant sa présidence à ce
qui le défend suffisamment son siège
pour vous je pense qu'il ya un
changement aujourd'hui
dans l'état d'esprit à la fois au niveau
des institutions européennes comme en
france pourquoi parce qu'il ya lobbying
il ya eu un travail qui est fait nous
travaillons et là je dis aussi sans
arrière pensée politique et en compte
quand c'est bien je suis aussi capable
de le dire et je ne fais pas que de la
politique politicienne comme certains
parfois le pensent travailler avec
clément bonne aujourd'hui bien ça a
porté ses fruits
ses secrétaires d'état effectivement aux
affaires européennes nous le voyons très
souvent travaillant de concert et c'est
une partie entre collectivités états et
parlement nous essayons de gagner
positivement sans forcément le dire il
ya eu des traités il faut respecter les
traités mais bien au contraire c'est de
se dire inventons une nouvelle histoire
européenne pour strasbourg faisons le en
confiance avec les autorités du
parlement européen faisons le faisons le
en confiance également avec qui le
député explique au mieux cette position
et portant une ambition pour strasbourg
en je crois que la france doit porter
l'ambition le président de la république
semble vouloir en tous les cas le risque
est il réel du départ du parlement
européen de strasbourg
les élus écologistes nos en se liant
ball certains il ya quelques temps ici
disait on brandit une espèce de peur on
est en alerte constante mais il faudrait
changer des tas de règles du jeu
européenne pour délocaliser le parlement
de strasbourg est ce que réellement il y
à un risque moi moi je ne pense pas
qu'il faille effectivement prendre un
départ je ne pense pas qu'il faille
mettre bruxelles luxembourg ou
strasbourg en concurrence chacune de ces
villes à sa place c'est quelle place
fait la france à strasbourg deuxième
capitale à l'intérieur de notre pays à
l'échelle de washington ou à l'échelle
de genève qui sont des capitales
mondiales qui sont des capitales
diplomatique sans être les capitales de
cette peine 2 de la suisse ou des états
unis bien strasbourg doit jouer le même
rôle ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on
amplifie ça veut dire qu'il faut
effectivement que sur l'échiquier
européen sur l'échiquier mondial
strasbourg soient clairement identifiés
il faut peut-être que nous montions
encore plus en force il faut que nous
augmentions le volume de strasbourg et
là il n'y aura plus de risques plus de
questionnements plus une interrogation
c'est pas simplement le passage de
strasbourg à à bruxelles de bruxelles à
strasbourg ça va au-delà c'est dans la
symbolique est dans la nécessité pour sa
seconde des pointes de d'être peut-être
une capitale européenne à part entière
avec un esprit peut être différent de
celui de bruxelles luxembourg c'est un
peu d'ailleurs ce que demande free
frédéric bierry un nouveau collègue des
républicains derrière qui lui redemande
une autonomie régionale pour l'alsace
dans lequel deux scores référendum il
est où le malaise là on a lui aussi
travaillé fort et berri avec gene
vincent ou pia ims à la tête de chaque
exécutif strasbourgeois ou alsacien pour
à la production strasbourg
une différence peut-être le jeu
politique de certains acteurs comme
ribéry qui souhaite revenir sur la loi
notre et la grande réalité des alsaciens
qui aujourd'hui sont passés à autre
chose et donc mais la première
préoccupation c'est l'emploi le pouvoir
d'achat
la majorité des égyptiens s'est
prononcée au mois de juin et aujourd'hui
je suis à la tête d'une région et le
vote et essien c'est comme porter
majoritairement là aussi sur ma personne
et mon équipe et mon projet et donc je
renvoie frédéric guéry aussi un moment
donné à une réalité démocratique
c'est ce que veut faire refleurir moi je
n'ai pas interférer dans
et décision interne de la collectivité
europe et
bien sûr pleinement partie et beaucoup
de synergies qui sont en train d'être
créés entre tout ce territoire mais ce
travail est bien du coup
c'est une collectivité site une
connectivité jeunes qui doit encore
mûrir nouant temps qui nous a encore
progressé palace et à la région
inversement c'est vrai qu'à ses lois est
encore plus jeune donc moi je l'invite
simplement en connaissant des
difficultés d'une fusion je sais ce que
ça veut dire mais surtout à travailler
en interne et à aboutir sur ce qui est
déjà été signé parce qu'il ya un accord
sur effectivement le chef de file à sur
les langues et cultures régionales sur
le transfrontalier tout cela c'est signé
j'attends juste des résultats pour
l'instant je ne vois pas aller on va
parler de la facture énergétique des
français puisque évidemment c'est une
inquiétude en les français qui voient
leur facture énergétique s'envoler le
gouvernement s'engage à contenir la
hausse à 4% cette année et pour cela il
demande à edf de vendre moins cher
l'électricité à ses concurrents ça
représente une perte d'environ 8
milliards pour edf qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette décision annoncée par
mois dans la merde
je comprends qu'il y ait une action qui
se fait sur le pouvoir d'achat des
français c'est de l'immédiateté là aussi
nous ne sommes pas dupes on est dans une
période très particulière
pour autant je considère que sur un plan
électoral oui messieurs et sur une
promesse qui a été faite avant d'en
donner de ne pas augmenter
à la charge sauf qui est une réalité et
la réalité c'est quand même de préserver
notre planète d'avoir un certain nombre
de prospective dans le temps et on sait
qu'en termes d'écologie en termes de
perspectives durables il faut être
plutôt long termiste et aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que dans l'accord qui a été
trouvé enfin dans l'accord de ce qui a
été imposé à edf
entreprises de services publics avec une
majorité quand même détenue par l'état
je crois hauteur de 84% si je ne me
trompe pas eh bien on demande à cette
entreprise de vendre à perte à des
concurrents qui eux n'ont en rien
investi dans l'avenir énergétique de la
france edf aujourd'hui il nécessite
effectivement de moderniser nos
réacteurs nucléaires 10 sont à l'arrêt
en ce moment il y a nécessité d'aller
probablement vers le p r il ya nécessité
aussi personnes n'ont pas de moderniser
nos réseaux électriques qui sont là
peut-être qu'ils doivent évoluer et à
côté ça il faut qu'on développe les
énergies renouvelables ça coûte de
l'argent il ya des décisions qui doivent
être prises et là on vient donc d'aucune
temps et 10 milliards d'euros
presque à edf comment edf inscrits sur
la mer que ça met en péril l'avenir
d'edf
pour moi il y à trois points le premier
c'est effectivement la forme la
stratégie et l'autonomie énergétique de
notre pays le deuxième c'est le pouvoir
d'achat de nos concitoyens c'est
important et la manière dont nos
entreprises là aussi vont se relever du
choc parce que il n'y a pas de plafond
pour nos entreprises que certaines
d'entre elles aujourd'hui sont mises en
faillite par cette hausse de
l'électricité et on ne fait rien pour
elle et la troisième c'est la production
de nerfs
edf est en outre tout cela est donc il
faut redonner des perspectives à cette
entreprise je n'ai pas entendu dans la
bouche du gouvernement aujourd'hui des
places petit qui soient données à nos
énergéticiens au sens large pour essayer
de nous projeter dans l'avenir
il le fait mieux de carmaux pour moi
sur la présidentielle et la question des
parrainages qu'il a aussi fait débat
vous faites partie des quelques 40 de
minelli qui sont habilités à parrainer
les candidats est-ce qu'il faut revoir
la règle pour voûté parrainage est ce
qu'aujourd'hui elle est obsolète
cet amuse on se pose toujours les règles
des élections
régionales départementales juste
quelques semaines avant est ce qu'il
faut voter à distance est ce que le vote
électronique est autorisée est ce que
c'est c'est assez particulier on se
reposer même question pour l'élection
présidentielle
c'est
pourquoi pourquoi espère un moment donné
on se pose pas ces questions bien avant
pas dans l'urgence oui il peut y avoir
un sujet effectivement sur les
parrainages oui on peut trouver d'autres
systèmes le double parrainage par
exemple père nage à la fois républicain
et a permis un parrainage citoyen de
citoyens oui
républicain il peut y avoir aussi un
collège d'élus de 200 mille élus ce qui
était aussi
proposée par certains jeux pour
permettre là aussi une la possibilité
aux candidats de se présenter les
différents systèmes mais faisons le loin
de ce débat lire mais finalement est qui
qui donne aux français le sens le
sentiment d'une forme soit de
précipitation soit de restrictions
soient de volonté de ne pas permettre à
certains de se présenter ce qu'ils ont
fait un bon ok c'est pas bon pas une
autre assise
présent c'est ça exactement le cas eric
zemmour jean luc mélenchon n'est sûr
gaccio et ils sont légitimes à se
présenter il fait ils ont fait acte de
candidature on voit que dans les
sondages bien ils marquent l'opinion
donc il faut que le débat puisse se fait
ce qu'il est nécessaire de les était là
c'est ça la question
je ne sais pas en tout cas un mouvement
politique n'a pas mené d un autre un
mouvement politique à ce concentré
derrière effectivement son candidat
c'est ce que nous faisons chez les
républicains d'un autre côté après la
démocratie le régime démocratique les
modes effectivement d'élections peuvent
être changées mais c'est là aussi au
pouvoir législatif de
de décider
les républicains ont validé les
républicains
il a dénoncé l'obsession de l'inclusion
concernant les enfants handicapés alors
il est un il est revenu un petit peu sur
ses propos les précisant mais bon il
expliqué qu'il est préférable
d'accueillir les enfants handicapés dans
des établissements spécialisés plutôt
que dans les classes avec les autres
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de ces
propos
j'ai pensé à mes parents
pourquoi parce que mes parents ont été
pendant toute leur vie au service
effectivement des personnes en situation
de handicap situation où je connais
particulièrement bien ils ont toujours
milité pour cette inclusion mixte à la
fois dans les institutions qui parfois
doivent prendre effectivement
de jeunes enfants ou des adultes en
situation de handicap comme une
inclusion dans la société mixte mais
quand j'entends monsieur zemmour qui
provoque la société qui pro qui va
chercher le débat j'ai parfois
l'impression de voir vous savez cet
instituteur dans les choristes un peu
vieillot par amour gris un peu sévère
qui ne donne pas de perspective qui ne
pardonne pas d'ouverture aux enfants
dans qui potentiellement pourrait avoir
la charge
j'ai l'impression d'avoir quelqu'un en
face de moi qui remet en cause aussi une
d un des éléments forts de notre devise
nationale l'égalité et l'égalité elle
concerne aussi les personnes en
situation de handicap et puis j'ai
l'impression d'avoir finalement
quelqu'un qui dit aimer la france mais
qui ne semble pas avoir de coeur et qui
n'aime pas les gens quand on fait la
politique il faut aimer les gens il faut
aller vers eux il ne faut pas simplement
être dans la provocation
gameplay qu'il était chez vous jusqu'à y
ait peu la rejoint
pour vous c'est un c'est un cas isolé où
il ya dans votre entourage d'autres
personnes qui pourraient être tentés de
rejoindre eric reiss est une jeune fille
question pour guillaume pelletier on le
savait tenté depuis longtemps par ce
genre d' aventure il a franchi le cap
pas tout commenté un acte isolé pour moi
merci beaucoup merci notre invité ce
matin
[Musique]